the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones house
of the dragon update video well my
friends it looks like george r martin
has given us another update about the
first season of house of the dragon
overrun is not a blog website in this
video i will show you what he said
because this new update shows us exactly
who has been writing hbo's new game of
thrones successor show
over on george rr martin's not a blog he
said house of the dragon has great show
runners and ryan condell and miguel
sapochnick and it has an amazing cast as
well you have been reading about them
for months
matt smith emma darcy milly alcock
olivia cook patty considine emily carey
rhee siphons steve toussaint fabian
frankel and more and more you may not
know their names now but i think you
will before the year ends you will hate
some of them love some of them and mourn
for some of them there's another group
of contributors equally important whose
names you might not know either but you
should without them there would be no
show if there was it certainly would not
be as good as i think house is going to
be here are the folks i am talking about
yes it's the writers house of the dragon
is based on my novellas the princess and
the queen and the rogue prince and other
materials from my targaryen history fire
and blood but fire in blood is an
imaginary history not a traditional
novel to turn it into a television
series requires a lot more work than
adapting a novel or a short story the
script writers need to make the history
come alive
ryan condo assembled an amazing team to
do just that the photograph above was
taken during one of my visits to la the
last i think before kovet descended on
us all and shut down my travels when i
sat down with ryan and his writers for
dinner it was a big loud lively dinner
at a long table but the food was great
and the company was greater i loved
talking the dragons with the team and i
was impressed with the depth of their
knowledge of my world and their
enthusiasm for the projects the first
season of house is now wrapped and in
large part thanks to the talents of our
scribes so raise your glasses and toast
our writers sarah hess gabe francesca
ira parker ty mackel charmaine de great
kevin lau and eileen shim and of course
ryan condell himself the ringmaster and
dragon tamer oh and though they are not
in the photo i should also salute claire
keachel and wes tuke who joined ryan and
ty in the mini writers room that
preceded this one before there was even
a pickup and me you ask no i did not
write a script for the first season of
house i would have loved to but i have
been kind of busy with ones of winner
the other game of thrones successor
shows various wild cards books dark
winds for amc road marks for hbo night
of the cooters and a couple other really
cool howard wall drop projects and well
yeah okay i bought a railroad never mind
now i did co-create the series with ryan
and help give it its shape and he and i
have been in constant contact ever since
hollywood is a land of change and the
writers are always moving around in
today's television landscape
some of the folks in the photo above
have moved on to other shows and other
networks before season one of house even
began to film others have been with us
all the way through the first season and
will be joining us for the second season
if indeed hbo gives us another one cross
your fingers
so here's to the writers
alright so there you have it ladies and
gentlemen you should now have an even
better idea of who actually wrote the
first season of house of the dragon
unfortunately george did not write an
entire episode in this first season like
he did on game of thrones but like he
said he has been of some help as you can
see here according to george he helped
give the series its shape and i'm sure
he helped ryan head in the right
direction since he says they were in
constant contact with one another now
thankfully he says he is still writing
the wins of winner although as we all
know he has said that for many many
years i'm not exactly sure if that means
we are any closer to actually getting
that novel
now another interesting thing he said
was he is also still helping create some
of the other game of thrones successor
shows now your guess is as good as mine
in regards to what those other shows
might actually be about as i've said
before i would watch a show on just
about anything set within george rr
martin's universe i would love to see a
show about aegon and his sister wives
and i would even still love to see a
show about the original long night
although i do doubt that hbo will ever
revisit that idea again considering they
already wasted 30 million dollars on a
pilot episode that will likely never see
the light of day for now let's just hope
that house of the dragon is an amazing
show first then i think we can start to
worry about what the other shows will
focus on from george rr martin's a song
of ice and fire universe let's hope that
everyone working on house of the dragon
will avoid making the same mistakes
david and dan made with game of thrones
i doubt that any of them want to face
that kind of backlash on this size of a
stage i will stay optimistic about
everything until they give me a reason
not to if george rr martin is excited
about house of the dragon then there is
no reason why i shouldn't be either make
sure you subscribe now if you want to
stay up to date on any and all
information regarding game of thrones
house of the dragon and a song of ice
and fire there will be many more videos
to follow as always i want to thank all
of you for watching this video i hope
you all have a great day i'll see you
soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
you